also something to keep in mind pretty
basic but louis c.k listen-only under
intimate situations caress knob great
it's been a year since the me to
movement made headlines and since then
we've realized that there are creeps
everywhere in hollywood on the news in
orange crux which we should have seen
coming and now on the supreme court for
a second time it's caused many to
redouble their efforts against sexual
assault and others to miss the point
completely it's a very scary time for
young men in america who are you scared
most for your son's daughter I mean
right now I'd say my son beyond the
trolls though some men are taking it
upon themselves to right the wrongs
exposed by the me to movement meet
Matthew Solomon I am an empowerment
coach I specialize in relationships and
communication and I wrote the book man
school relating with women in the me to
era do men need a class I'm not sending
an unsolicited dick pic a whole class on
that maybe not but as part of the class
evidently because it happens all the
time man school covers topics like rape
culture in movies toxic masculinity and
issues that have stumped dudes from
millennia such as women are not men what
compelled you to write man school women
started posting their stories with the
hashtag me too and even knowing the
magnitude of it seeing it there was so
humbling and it was so overwhelming but
there were all these men who had no idea
and they didn't know how to react and
how to respond and because they would
speak up and do that do the stuff that
people do things like harassment gas
lighting what about ISM and telling
women their experiences don't matter
yeah we've been on the Internet
do you find it ironic that you're a guy
that has to explain all these things
that women have been saying for years
no why not because I know that men
haven't generally been listening to
women for years so you're like
mansplaining sexism which is pretty much
to men it's
good mansplaining if your mansplaining
two men maybe it's good if a man's man I
don't know I have got lost in the in
this space continuum of sexism
everything you're saying sounds great
but how do I know you're not like that
guy who wears the feminist t-shirt but
then like a secretly kind of a creep
yeah I'm not you sure yeah I'm sure okay
okay Matthew let's put your methods to
the test with a real man school we
gathered seven dudes in a room on a
Friday to give them a lesson and how to
be one of the good guys in the me to era
and also to hear from you
welcome to man school I'm learning 2,000
years of patriarchy thank you for being
here I would love to know from each of
you and what you hope to get out of
today I realized how sexist I've been
and not even realizing that was a
problem you know it's been a continual
process for me to learn how to interact
with women especially like compared to I
don't know my freshman year of college
where you get a ton of bad advice I've
been getting close and relationships but
once I hit a certain point I kind of
screw it up I want to you guys like what
are your fears men are becoming
uncomfortable in their own skin because
of what we're seeing so is there a
concern about where the line is what you
can or can't do you know there are
people who legitimately when they
interact sexually like play like play
violence or something like that I think
that that's maybe one thing that some
guys are worried about there is that
fear you know hey so you get with
somebody in Palm Springs during a film
festival and you have mad rocking sex
because you drank a bunch of Tito's and
soda you know what I'm saying why does
this example feel not hypothetical
that's okay
they're sharing why isn't there like a
consent app where like people could sign
in and you just said yes or no you know
I think
I bet there is a consent app I bet that
exists but my understanding is that
consent has to be a continual thing so
like even if you hit yes I'm down right
now you have the right to change your
mind unless the app is constantly
sending you notifications of three of
the consent oh my god they're pitching
an app triggered so let me ask you this
what are some of the things that you as
men do to ensure your safety on a daily
basis I try to have different passwords
for all of my website so in regards to
personal safety women have shared 34
things that they do on a daily basis
yeah 34 things in for their personal
safety walk with our keys grass between
our fingers in case we need to use them
as a weapon
never leave a drink unattended at a
party run off the street when we see men
who look like they might be drunk
definitely do that
make sure we're not the only woman on
the subway or bus are going to get you a
light post when it's dark outside decide
not to open facebook messages from
unknown men who could see the message
that have been read and become hostile
and harassing yes you do become hostile
would never occur to me to do 90% of the
stuff on that list but if shocking to
see you go yup yup yep to everyone you
recognized oh well there's someone that
I kind of have questions about details
on like for example if you do happen to
be walking behind a woman at night is it
better to speed up and pass her to slow
down to distance I mean what about bells
could also work we have whistles you
have bells with just a very Merry
sidewalk what else can we do to make
women feel safe use our male priviledge
to call out problematic males go out and
affirmative ly express your support when
there's an issue that's being discussed
that's of importance to women some
orange haired knucklehead a couple weeks
ago so it's a rough time for young men
in this country you need to be held
accountable we need to educate ourselves
we need to educate our young sons her
experiences her experience the thing
that she's telling you that's what
happened so in other words it's helpful
acronym bra believe rape account homey
homey we believe those rape accounts
with heart open-mindedness intelligence
and empathy so we're gonna put that into
practice yeah let's put that into
practice and we need a volunteer
Francesca is confiding in you something
that happened you know possibly a me-too
moment or a story with somebody who's
been misbehaving and so you get to as
the man get her experience and support
her in that moment I don't I know this
is hard to hear but your brother just
grabbed my butt completely like two
hands full palms I'm so sorry to hear
that I mean I'm surprised to hear that
but I'm really really sorry to hear that
because that's that's not okay
that's not cool is there anything I can
do just tell me not to touch your
friends you know tell them not to touch
anyone awesome how was that you know I'm
thinking about my own brothers and
you know that would never I can't
imagine that happening without my own
brother so it was hard for me to sort of
put myself in a place where I would
relate to that but I suppose that in
life but you kind of have to get over
that because there are people in your
life that are going to surprise you so
so for this next scenario Francesca is
going to be playing the man who's saying
inappropriate things about women and so
Juan here gets to speak up be an ally
Brett is a really good guy like I don't
know what all these women are talking
about I never saw Brett act that way
I've known him for years there dude
you're not gonna see it from him but I
was with him all through all of high
school prep school college obviously
she's doing it for the money and for the
fame name one of Cosby's accusers one
that got paid um there's a tennis player
time out awesome awesome
so so in this scenario we're getting
into the the debate right what if
instead of arguing the facts you came
from what are you suppose it was like
for her interesting so I'm supposed to
try to get him to empathize but the
other big thing try to okay cool
how about you have evidence of the rape
before you go around accusing a bunch of
men am i really friends with this dude
talking about you know me forever
it's chat three hours later and these
males are finally ready to be released
back into the wild you guys made it
you've done man school and while there
are no cookies for doing the right thing
in real life there are in man school and
prizes I learned about Brock believe
reap the count homie
I need to be more sympathetic in
conversation and ask more questions I
think it's the big two like things to
take away you don't really get too many
opportunities to see people sort of open
up and actually express what their
innermost thoughts and feelings are
about losing especially Matt so that was
really refreshing for me what should
women understand about men in the me2
era that men are extremely sensitive you
know we have feelings and emotions that
were not really taught that we're
allowed to have those and then we're
sure as heck can't express those do you
think there should be a man school
absolutely I think there should be a man
school there should be a teen school
relationships and communication should
be taught as party curriculum so will
men ever be able to unlearn patriarchy
maybe not after one class but hey the
first step is showing up
[Music]